مئات الالاف من المواطنين هنا في شمال
قطاع غزه لا يجدون ماوى لهم بسبب القصف
المتواصل وبسبب تدمير الاحتلال لمنازلهم
فمنهم من يحاولون البحث عن ماوى لهم
ليستقروا به لكن هنا بعض العائلات جاءت
الى هذه المدرسه التي دمرها الاحتلال
ليعيشوا هنا تحت ركام هذه المدرسه التي تم
تدميرها هنا في مخيم جباليا من قبل قوات
احتلال زي ما انت شايف الوضع اغرقنا بره
في الخيم و وفي المطر اضطرينا نستصلح
منطقه هي بتسرب ميه من هنا بتكب مي من هنا
بتكب مي بس استصلح ل منطقه اللي نسطر فيها
حالنا احنا واولادنا الصغار اي فش غطا فش
فراش فش اكل فش شرب وهي هنا ميه مطر ومنها
بنستخدم ونطبخ وانا هلقيت ركبت على الطبيخ
لاولادي من الميه هذه من قله الميه ومن ما
في لا ميه حلوه ولا ميه صالحه للاستخدام
الصبح مثلا بيطلعوا يدوروا على حطب هذا مش
يوميا كل يومين ثلاثه الاكل هي مره واحده
في اليوم هي مكاننا هي الحطب هذا لما بموه
اولادي يعني بمعاناه والله سترهم المره
اللي فاتت في القصف استهدفوا عنا اثنين
هنا وهم بموا الحطب واستشهدوا الشباب
والله سلم الاولاد يعني كلها خوف وخوف
ورعب رعب هذه جوره هنا مفتوحه على الناس
هذه حطينا لها الجلديات هذه والحداق
عشان الصغار ما يقعو هان حاولت هنا اعمل
فرن عشان لو توفر الطحين اخبز لكن ما ضبطت
الامور وما فيش طحين اصلا كمان بس ايش بده
يسوي الواحد وين بده يروح ما فيش اماكن
دورنا راحت تشردنا من اماكنا من جوع لعطش
ما فيش ميه لا لاكل لا ل طبيخ للاا غسيل
يعني انا غسلت اليوم غسيل بميه المطر لما
يجي حدا حرك او هذا بقع علينا رمل من
السقف انت شايف الرمل هي بقع على وجهي
قاعد احنا هينا ساكنين انا والاولاد كنا
بيت درج يعني وبنعرف ننام من السقعه وهي
المدرسه كلها يعني مكسوفه ولا في طحين ولا
في ميه ولا في حاجه هذ مش عيشه يعني ما ما
فيش ما فيش امان نروي على الدور فيش
خايفين نرو على الدور من رم انا شيل علينا
وطلعنا مندور مش قادرين نرجع بنروح بعرضنا
للخطر وين نروح وين نروح في ويا نقعد فيها
اجينا في المدرسه تاعت الوكاله وهي هدام
تاعت الوكاله كمان هدوها وسقف مهدود هذا
مين بيعيش فيه غير ربنا الساتر اذا هكذا
هو المشهد هنا في شمال غزه في ظل اشتداد
هذه الحرب واشتداد الحصار مئات الالاف من
المواطنين لا يجدون ماوى لهم ولا يجدون
طعام ولا ماء للاستمرار في الحياه انس
الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه i